Now let's start here,
with the desktop computer
many of us have spent countless hours
working with to build and use software.
It looks conventional and familiar
only because we've each spent so
much time with it.
But something you'll notice about all
these devices when you look at them
without anything else in the picture.
It's hard to see the human.
Now one of my favorite thought
experiments is by the VR
pioneer, Jaron Lanier.
You may have heard this before, so
just bear with me for a moment.
What if aliens came to Earth and people
were nowhere to be found, and what if
these aliens tried to figure out what
we were like based on our computers.
What would they think?
DI mean do we have a hundred and
two fingers and one big eye?
Now if they look to the hammer,
he'd make more sense.
You can almost see the arm that would
wield this tool and hammer in nails.
But this computer?
I mean, just look at that keyboard,
it's not really built for us,
in fact, it's not even built for
us to type fast.
Back when this keyboard
layout was designed,
it was intended to keep
us from typing so fast,
that these tight bars would get caught
together and screw everything up.
But this, is what evolved
into the modern keyboard.
Now this is a very physical difference
between a person and a machine.
Let's look at a less physical
difference that's just as dangerous.
Now what's wrong with this picture?
In many ways,
this is our relationship to technology
today, it gives us a lot of value.
However, we're adapting our lifestyle
to the technology that assists us,
and there's a heavy cost, distraction.
We pay that cost frequently.
But what if we didn't have to?